.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MARK ANTONIO WRIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: PUTIN'S INVASION HAS
CAUSED UKRAINE TO SPIRAL INTO A
FULL BLOWN HUMANITARIAN
CATASTROPHE WHERE VIOLENCE,
STARVATION AND LOOTING PLAGUE
THE STREETS.
TREY YINGST IS ON THE GROUND IN
KYIV WITH THE LATEST.
TREY?
>>
>> JESSE, CONCERNING
DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE BUT SPECIFICALLY IN
THE PORT CITY OF MARIUPOL WHERE
THERE ARE CIVILIANS CUT OFF FROM
THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
YOU CAN SEE IN THIS VIDEO THE
RUSSIAN SHELLINGS CONTINUE
AGAINST THIS CITY.
THE SHELLINGS HAVE CUT OFF WATER
SUPPLY AND POWER SUPPLY.
SETTING UP A MASSIVE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THIS CITY HAS A POPULATION OF
AROUND 400,000 PEOPLE AND IT IS
STRATEGIC FOR RUSSIAN FORCES TO
CAPTURE SO THEY CAN CONNECT
THEIR FRONT LINES.
THERE WERE VIDEOS POSTED ONLINE
SHOWING PEOPLE LOOTING LOCAL
SHOPPING MALLS WHILE OTHER AREAS
OF THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING TAPED TO LAMP
POOLS BY LOCALS AS THEY ATTEMPT
TO STEAL THINGS IT GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF THE DESPERATION.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FACING NOT
UNIQUE TO THE SOUTH BUT THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY AS RUSSIAN FORCES
ADVANCE TONIGHT ACROSS EUROPE.
MANY ARE DEMONSTRATING IN
SUPPORT OF THE UKRAINIANS.
IN GEORGIA THE CZECH REPUBLIC,
GERMANY WE HAVE SEEN ANTIWAR
PROTEST ERUPT.
THOUSANDS IN THE STREETS.
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE SEE THIS
SOLIDARITY BUT IT'S REALLY NOT
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED RIGHT
NOW.
THEY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT BUT
THEY NEED SUPPLIES.
THEY NEED SANCTIONS AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
AND THEY NEED WEAPONS.
TO PUSH BACK AGAINST THIS
OFFENSIVE THAT DOES CONTINUE